[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 c'est par sipa c'est
parti pour le sommaire de ce un magazine
football plaisir s'est imposé sur son
teint contre rosny-sur-seine lors des
huitièmes de finale de la coupe des
yvelines le score 4 1 le résumé du match
dans ce magazine course à pied zoom sur
jeanne le corps à 16 ans cette sportive
l'essentiel le à saint quentin en
yvelines est l'une des pépites à suivre
dans les yvelines son portrait dans
cette émission cyclisme coup de
projecteur aujourd'hui sur le paris-nice
2022 la course au soleil partira du
département pour la 13ème année
consécutive en mars prochain ce sera
notre module découverte l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tv 78
on commence par du football et la coupe
de france vous le savez tous on suit
leur épopée sur tv 60,18 versailles
s'est qualifié pour les huitièmes de
finale de la coupe de france en battant
la roche-sur-yon 4 à 0 au début janvier
on connaît désormais leur prochain
adversaire le tirage a eu lieu ce mardi
4 janvier au prochain tour versailles va
affronter l'équipe de toulouse l'équipe
de toulouse est actuellement deuxième de
ligue 2 ils sont en course pour la
montée on écoute le capitaine de
l'équipe de versailles
pour moi c'est un bon tirage c'est quand
même l'équipe professionnelle comme
comme vous l'avez dit c'est sa jolie au
tableau en ligue 2 c'est offensivement
c'est très fort
c'est sûr qu'on aurait aimé et un gros
d'hier pour le public les supporters
pour leur ferveur mais bon c'est ça
reste comme une équipe professionnelle
et se mesurer face à l'unique contre
c'est toujours intéressant mais monette
mais mauvaise nouvelle pour les
versailles est l'un des petits poucets
de la compétition ne jouera pas domicile
à toulouse le samedi 29 janvier à 16h30
le stade mot bord on n'est pas homologué
pour organiser cette rencontre la
structure sportive et privés d'éclairage
en soirée à cause d'une trop grande
proximité avec la chambre du roi du
château de versailles aucune source
lumineuse ne doit être visible dans un
rayon de 5 km vous l'aurez compris les
règles sont les règles ont continué à
parler football et de la première
titularisation du versailles et edouard
michelin dans le onze du paris saint
germain les viennois de 18 ans a joué en
16e de finale de la coupe de france face
aux amateurs de vannes le lundi 3
janvier victoire 4 à 0 le jeune milieu
de terrain a même touché là transversale
en fin de match il a déclaré après la
rencontre s'entraîner dur pour ce genre
de moments edouard michu est également
entré en jeu lors du match de ligue 1
contre lyon ce dimanche soir il a
délivré la passe décisive sur le but du
parisien carer score final 1 partout on
continuera à suivre les performances du
versailles et dans les approches un mois
encore du football ont joué à ce
week-end les huitièmes de finale de la
coupe des yvelines dans le match qui
opposait à plaisir à rosny-sur-seine ce
sont les plaisirs oies qui ont réussi à
se qualifier pour le prochain tour le
résumé du match des images de justin
brasil
plaisir face à rosny-sur-seine c'était
l'une des affiches de ces huitièmes de
finale de la coupe des yvelines deux
équipes qui évoluent en d2 de district
les visiteurs du nord du département
ouvre la marque dans les premières
minutes du match sur cette action mais
l'avantagé de courte durée jours de
plaisirs arrive à combiner et pousse le
défenseur à la faute un partout les
plaisirs wa marque une nouvelle fois
juste avant la pause 2-1 au moins on
remarque assez tôt dès raids ailleurs
que ça nous met en confiance et après je
réponde à un abus de confiance donc on
joue moins bien et à prendre dans nos
travers mais la première mettant ça va
dans l'ensemble ça va on doit les deux
premiers buts qui les lancent dans le
match et inscrire ce point que première
mi-temps assez mitigées avec un terrain
catastrophique on devait jouer sur le
synthétique mais ils étaient inondés
donc on a joué sur le sueur sur le
terrain en herbe terrain une terrain
catastrophique comme je vous le dis avec
beaucoup de faux rebonds on est une
équipe qui joue au ballon là on a dû
déjouer avec des longs ballons en
seconde période plaisir semble mieux
apprivoiser le terrain 45 minutes à sens
unique où les locaux plus frais
physiquement arriverons a marqué à deux
reprises quinze minutes après le retour
des vestiaires puis cinq minutes plus
tard le score est sans appel 4 1 à la
fin des 90 minutes on avait à coeur de
commencer bien 2022 on savait que en
coupons c'était notre domaine de
prédilection
si on a fait un grand parcours en coupe
de france on se fait éliminer par une 3e
penalty et donc la huitième de finale il
fallait qu'on rapporte ce match on
savait que c'était un match éliminatoire
butoir donc on a fait un match assez
prolifique en buts avec 4 buts à notre
actif
direction à présent les quarts de finale
pour le club avec un objectif en tête
ramener la coupe à la maison le prochain
match est programmé le 20 février
on continue à parler de la coupe des
yvelines avec notre journaliste grégory
à canal et qui remplace notre
chroniqueur habituel bixente mérian
senti stevan bonsoir grégory beaud for
michael je ferme mon mieux pour le
remplacer j'en doute pas on commence
donc par la coupe des yvelines on l'a
vue dont plaisir qui s'est imposé 4 1 à
domicile contre rosny sur seine dans les
autres rencontres michael chatou s'est
imposé 1 0 sur la pelouse de houille
même score pour villennes orgeval sur le
terrain de chambourcy voisin écrase
bailly noisy sur le score de 6 à 2
conflans s'impose 1 à 0 face à
rambouillet enfin des mureaux s'impose
dans le derby 1 à 0 face à l'équipe 3 du
fc mantois et le match aussi
spectaculaire entre marly-le-roi et
hardricourt 3 à 2 pour les mariés choix
le match entre trappe et d'argent ville
a quant à lui été reporté toujours en
coupe mais cette fois-ci de la coupe de
france et du volleyball ce samedi à 8
janvier le club de conflans andrésy jouy
recevait mende qui évoluent en ligue b
une division plus haut que les yvelinois
et la hiérarchie a été respectée
les joueurs du département se sont
inclinés lors de ce deuxième tour de la
compétition le score 3 sets à 1 le caj
volley ball va maintenant se
reconcentrer sur le championnat élite le
club est pour l'instant la troisième
place après neuf journées en rugby dans
le championnat de fédérale 2 le match
entre plaisir et gennevilliers a
finalement été reportée au dimanche 13
février à la veille de la saint-valentin
à cause de plusieurs cas est de covile
19 dans ses effectifs les plaisirs war
reste donc à la huitième place du
classement après une journée 11 journées
de championnat disputées et un mot de
course course automobile pour terminer à
michael yvelinois elle jean pierre
garcin participe en ce moment une course
légendaire le dakar 2022 il est le co
pilote de lionel bocher ph sport à bord
d'une peugeot 3008 ils sont pour
l'instant 50e du classement général mais
la compétition n'est pas terminée elle
l'homme qui totalise 23 participations
au total sur le paris-dakar nous a
envoyé cette vidéo est depuis l'arabie
saoudite pour nous décrire son quotidien
regarder
c'est la fameuse journée les mécaniciens
ont travaillé depuis hier soir avec un
pseudo
nous personnellement on à passer pour
une mauvaise semaine avec un chat noir
dans la voiture
quand c'est le cas car c'est comme ça on
a même vu
bonne nuit dans le désert galéré et
caetera et ouais c'est pas grave
c'est de faire plaisir
les soucis
on espère vraiment la deuxième semaine
sera bien meilleur il reste
six jours du causse sud de course et
et c'est tout
il ya encore des belles journées
peinture n'est cette année la priorité
c'était les nuls les duels et une
du sable
locke et au départ ils passent très
expérimenté mais pas trop ça maintenant
adore il fait plaisir et ça franchement
c'est chouette
donc on va on va tenir le coup et
je suis sûr qu'on va se faire
belles spéciales et on aura un bon
résultat voilà et puis
jada et puis
effet dès cette fin de rallye 2022
on a senti l'ambiance y est atypique
l'ambiance sonore sur les paris dakar on
souhaite bien sûr bon courage à jean
pierre garcin il paris dakar le dakar on
l'appelle maintenant le dakar se
terminera ce vendredi 14 janvier merci
grégory pour toutes ces précisions et ce
tour d'horizon des résultats sportifs du
week end dans les yvelines on ouvre une
page course à pied jade le corps du club
de l'entente athlétique de saint quentin
en yvelines a remporté le titre de
championne de france cadette de cross en
novembre dernier à meaux tombant entre
entraînements et rigueur la jeune
yvelinoise de 16 ans est un véritable
espoir pour sa discipline son portrait
par céline charme
avec quatre à cinq entraînements par
semaine les efforts de jade le corps on
pays elle a su saisir la première place
du podium dans la catégorie cadette lors
des championnats de france de cross en
novembre dernier quand je suis parti je
pensais vraiment pas faire podium
je visais un top 5 et bas pendant la
cour me suis vraiment senti bien donc
j'ai vu qu'on commence à détacher des
autres filles donc après je suis parti
et
ça a payé spécialisée dans le demi fond
elle a commencé l'athlétisme à 11 ans
performance et chrono surprenant la
jeune femme qui s'entraîne au club de
l'entente athlétique de saint quentin en
yvelines ne cesse d'impressionner
j'ai commencé parce qu'on m'a repéré en
sixième au cross et du coup après je me
suis inscrit au club et je faisais un
peu toutes les spécialités
et après abandonné je voulais spécialisé
en demi fond parce que c'est ce que je
préférais début
je m'entraînais comme ça et puis on a
commencé à faire plus d'entraînement a
programmé plus de compet des minimes 2
elle a montré des qualités qui sont
rares arad de quelques dixièmes le
record de france sur 1000 m pour sa
deuxième année de demi fond et puis et
puis l'an dernier en cadettes pareil à
la sortie des chronos très surprenant
ok je m'attendais pas forcément dès que
couture authenti ça devient c'est à dire
une athlète qui est très forte
mentalement
qui comme je dis qu'il va à la guerre
quand elle a pas peur de la bagarre et
de haies
et chercher l'échiquier vraiment de se
faire mal en compétition véritable
espoir pour la suite jade rêve comme ces
exemples gimmi gressier où hugo est
d'atteindre les jeux olympiques je pense
que ton de ces régions est bon je pense
que j'ai le temps et de continuer à
faire des sélections
à mon âge le 1500 et les les jo-2020
ensuite j'aimerais bien los angeles
chance que j'aurai peut être dans
les meilleures européennes pour être mûr
euros place de sa catégorie une
motivation à toute épreuve et des
résultats qui suivent la championne qui
fait jusqu'à trois compétitions par mois
pourrait rapidement gravir les échelons
en tennis si on ne sait pas encore si
novak djokovic va participer ou non à
l'open d'australie un ebe noah
participera bel et bien ce tournoi du
grand chelem qui débute ce lundi 17
janvier selon arthur rinderknecht saint
germanois de 26 ans désormais 58e
mondial espère aller le plus loin
possible dans la compétition
ces derniers matches prouve qu'il est en
forme il a battu l'australien james
duckworth lors de la tp cup et s'est
bien défendu mais a perdu contre
l'italien yannick sinner dc qualifié
aujourd'hui en huitièmes de finale du
tournoi d'adélaïde 2 de bonne augure
pour l'open d'australie chat si vous
êtes passionné de cyclisme sur piste ce
rendez vous peut vous intéresser 24
équipes dont des sprinteurs de l'équipe
de france seront présents ce samedi 15
janvier pour participer à la troisième
édition des 6 heures de saint quentin en
yvelines l'événement est programmée de
12h à 18h avec des épreuves hommes
femmes est mixte un autre rendez vous
cycliste a noté adam vos agendas le
paris-nice 2022 la course au soleil
partira une nouvelle fois à des yvelines
en mars prochain tv 78 s'est rendu à la
conférence de presse la semaine dernière
à regarder
[Musique]
nous sommes le mercredi à 5 janvier
aujourd'hui c'est la présentation
officielle du paris-nice 2022 ici à
versailles il passera pour la treizième
année consécutive dans les yvelines
[Musique]
comme depuis treize ans le paris-nice
partira depuis deux communes des
yvelines regardez ce reportage c'est
devenu une routine depuis 13 ans la
conférence de presse du paris-nice est
programmée en janvier à l'hôtel du
département à versailles les
organisateurs dévoilent le parcours
officiel et à la fin deux communes des
yvelines sont désignés comme ville
départ une grande et une petite ce 5
janvier ses manques la ville vingt mille
habitants qui a été retenue pour lancer
cette course au soleil une boucle de
159,8 km à travers les yvelines avec
départ et arrivée boulevard roger
salengro le 6 mars on est bien sûr très
très très heureux on a candidaté
et on a pu donc avoir cette
merveilleuse nouvelle de pouvoir être la
ville non seulement l'état mais
également dans ceux de départ évidemment
ça va mettre en lumière notre notre
commune on est bien sûr très heureux le
7 mars la deuxième étape partira de la
petite commune d'auffargis direction
orléans le village de 2000 habitants
étaient traversées à plusieurs reprises
par le tour de france et ce sera une
nouvelle fois un événement pour la
commune ce n'est pas la première fois
que paris nice passe dans le village
mais c'est la première fois qu'il y à un
départ d'étape de paille disent nous
sommes ravis ça va faire de l'animation
un village qui est déjà très animée mais
ça va engager aussi tous nos bénévoles
qui sont là toujours présent puisque
c'est quand même une belle organisation
on est bien aidé par esso mais c'est
quand même une grosse organisation pour
un petit village comme la nôtre cette
13ème édition consécutive dans les
yvelines portera-t-elle chance à ces
deux communes zibi noise réponse les 6
et 7 mars prochains à mes côtés à
françois lemarchand le directeur du
tracé par françois lemarchand dans les
yvelines ça partira de mantes-la-ville
pourquoi bien comme tous les ans on
change enfin on change de mon change
d'endroit oui on change de ville
cc on travaille en étroite collaboration
avec le département des yvelines donc
voilà les villes sont opposés et nous on
va voir sur le terrain celles qui
conviennent techniquement je parle bien
techniquement et puis bah c'était
logique que mantes la ville
accueil cette première étape de paris
nice nantes la ville qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que ça représente pour un
pendant départ c'est quand même une
ville assez assez importante et sa
marque sur une carte quand on voit la
carte de de paris-nice tracé général de
paris nice montre la ville c'est quand
même quelque chose qui parle on allait
mantes-la-jolie donc ça va faire le
distinguo entre mantes-la-jolie
mantes-la-ville donc en termes de
communication c'est excellent et puis
c'est toujours c'est toujours assez
important pour nous organisateurs lâche
parle de faire découvrir des villes
grâce aux grâce à ce sport grâce au
sport cycliste parce que c'est le
meilleur moyen de médiatiser certaines
villes et est d'aller et d'aller dans
les villes avec avec paris nice parlez
nous de cette première étape donc c'est
une boucle oui il ya une première boucle
de 140 km alors on va aller en deux
on va traverser la seine au nord pour
aller chercher une partie du vexin puis
après on va revenir vers le tout chez
apple val d'oise après on va revenir
vers revenir sur scène donc la cdc des
routes qu'on n'avait jamais emprunté sur
sur paris 10 donc on va faire découvrir
un petit peu le département c'est normal
faut que tout le monde en profite après
un dur assure aux dents pour remonter
ensuite sur sûrement de la ville faire
un passage suis arrivé pour les chercher
le circuit final de 20 km mais c'est
pour quels types de coureurs cette étape
je dirais sprinteurs parce que
logiquement les premières étapes de
paris-nice et pour les sprinteurs mais
l'histoire l'histoire récente nous a
nous a prouvé le contraire que ce soit à
bois d'arcy où tu sois plaisir
ben y'a pas des sprinteurs tout
simplement parce que la météo a fait a
fait son aaa jouer le jeu a joué le jeu
et si on peut dire avec l'appui avec le
vent donc voilà par défaut aux
sprinteurs mais bon après ça c'est la
course c'est le sport qui décide
deuxième étape qui partira d'auffargis
un village de 2000 habitants à peu près
un village de 2000 habitants oui ce que
je disais tout à l'heure
le maire dans les années 60 c'est félix
lévitan si un conte directeur du tour de
france donc une partie vélo moi même
quand je quand je courais chez les
amateurs je crois beaucoup aux farges
hisse donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui qui qui qui qui parle au milieu
cycliste il ya beaucoup de deux groupes
cyclistes qui font du vélo tous les week
ends dans cette vallée de chevreuse qui
passaient auffargis donc un petit clin
d'oeil aux farges et c'était sympa et
c'est l'occasion aussi de mettre en
valeur chaque fois le territoire d yves
hinse et toujours le choix de prendre la
grosse ville et la petite ville le
lendemain oui parce que en termes de
structure c'est moins important
une structure du vide d'arriver il faut
une belle ligne droite il faut il faut
un gymnase pour faire la salle de presse
où une grande salle des fêtes vous faire
ce qui n'est pas forcément le cas sur
les petites communes est en revanche
pour s'installer pour les petites
communes et bien on peut s'installer
partout on a fait les bréviaires où on
peut s'installer dans les champs là
c'est peut-être un peu moins pratique
mais on trouve des solutions donc on
peut amener le vélo vraiment vraiment
vraiment dans les petites communes donc
c'est encore une fois c'est c'est
l'intérêt de notre sport et c'est pour
ça qu'il me rioux oui c'est un sport
démocratique on peut le dire tout le
monde peut venir voir et qui est
gratuite qui est gratuit qui amène les
champions 1 le voir les champions pour
avoir l'équipe de france il faut le
stade de france tandis que la basse et
le stade de france qui va dans les
petites villes qui va ou par jc qui va
maman je la vis donc c'est formidable de
la question ça fait 13 ans du cookie par
des limites est ce qu'on arrive quand
même à se renouveler chaque année à
trouver des nouvelles routes gérées sans
couilles oui bah il faut mais à un
moment on va tourner en jeu pas dire
qu'on va tourner en rond mais on nous
notre métier d'organisateur de cesser de
ne pas faire comme d'habitude c'est de
casser les codes et et on trouve trouve
toujours on trouve toujours des
solutions compte toujours dix occasions
quand on est ancien coureur ton toujours
des solutions merci françois lemarchand
c'est beaucoup
alors pierre bédier 13 ans que le paris
nice passe ici par les yvelines il part
des îles par des élus mais il passe
ensuite dans les yvelines il par la
première étape est un contre la montre
dans une ville est la première étape de
route qui est donc le lendemain le lundi
se passe toujours à partir d'un village
parce qu'on essaye comme ça de faire
voir le double aspect des yvelines des
villes magnifiques des villages superbe
et entre les deux des paysages
exceptionnels qu'est ce que vous pensez
des choix de mantes la ville et de fargy
cette année mais je pense du bien
puisque c'est nous yvelinois qui
choisissons ça fait partie du
partenariat avec à etsaut donc d'une
année sur l'autre
après le départ nous choisissons après
vérification technique parce que il est
important d'assurer la mise en sécurité
des coureurs cyclistes c'est un sport
qui va vite et donc quand il ya des
chutes on l'a vu l'année dernière à la
dernière étape elles sont spectaculaires
et dangereuse donc il faut s'assurer que
techniquement les villes puissent être
des villes de départ et une fois qu'on a
cette assurance on prévient les maires
pour savoir s'ils sont intéressés
généralement ils le sont je n'ai essuyé
aujourd'hui encore aucun refus on avait
avec nous au juste avant françois
lemarchand le directeur du tracé et nous
disait finalement on ne tourne pas en
rond après 13 ans est ce que ces
sentiments-là oui parce que vous avez un
territoire qui est quand même assez
vaste qui a
beaucoup de diversité
et c'est vrai que
je crois qu'on aura encore au moins
treize ans de découvertes avant d'être
obligé de revenir
sur les lieux deux précédentes étapes
parce que c'est cette force des hybrides
j'ai lu récemment dans un quotidien que
je ne nommerai pas le quotidien régional
parisien que beaucoup de visites
ministérielles se passer dans les
yvelines parce que c'est une mini france
les yvelines je vous le confirme c'est
le cas pour le cyclisme aussi on n'a pas
la haute montagne j'en suis désolé pour
pour les montagnards il avait connu des
longs cours communs mais il ya quand
même quelques difficultés quelques côtes
un peu raide et est donc cette très
grande diversité de paysages fait c'est
très bien pique nique mans pour les
organisateurs et c'est très bien pour
les téléspectateurs
il y a eu cette année un million trois
cent mille personnes qui ont découvert
les yvelines à travers des images du
paillis le paris-nice passera par les
emmy jusqu'en 2025 c'est le partenariat
qui a été signé est ce que ça pourrait
aller au delà de 2025 alors oui nous en
avons parlé avec christian prudhomme jeu
mais confirmé qu'on s'est installé dans
un temps très très long et que donc nous
souhaitions conserver ce partenariat le
renouvellera partenariat avec
l'organisateur aso pour paris nice mais
partenariat aussi pour la dernière étape
du tour de france puisque nous avons un
départ de la dernière étape des yvelines
depuis deux ou trois ans alors nous
n'aurons l'année prochaine et je peux
vous dire que nous partirons du de
montigny dans de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du
vélodrome parce que le vélodrome va
accueillir les épreuves cyclistes des
jeux olympiques de 2024 il y aura une
suspension de la dernière étape du tour
en 2024 christian prudhomme garde secret
cette étape mais comme c'est juste avant
les jeux olympiques
je pense que ça va être quelque chose
d'un peu particulier et à partir de 2025
nous reprendrons cette habitude donc
paris nice au printemps et l'été dernier
étape du tour de france merci permet de
lire si
christian prudhomme à quoi va ressembler
ce paris-nice 2022 je rêverais qu'il
ressemble aussi à celui de 2021 c'est à
dire qu'on est un final haletant
renforcement de situation puisque vous
en souvenez le numéro 1 mondial de
l'époque prime aux riches avaient
largement dominé la compétition remporté
trois étapes on le voyait dominateur
écrasant et vainqueur à nice et puis le
dernier jour une chute un pépin
mécanique d'un coéquipier et
il perd tout il ya un renversement de
situation absolument inattendu
invraisemblable donc c'est aussi la
marque de paris nice c'est à dire que
quels que soient les les coureurs au
départ il est vraiment certains
peut-être plus encore sur cette épreuve
lac sur les autres que tant qu'on n'a
pas franchi la ligne d'arrivée finale on
n'a pas gagné par annie c'est une
épreuve qui joue souvent à coups de
secondes
la moyenne entre le premier et le
deuxième c'est une dizaine d'une
douzaine de secondes c'était un peu plus
l'an passé mais après un final
absolument renverser ans donc j'ai envie
de vous dire voilà le nom du vainqueur
de paris-nice qu'on connaît la dernière
minute ça nous va bien un final à
hitchcock c'est quelque chose qui nous
plaît chaque année et puis ce qui nous
fait aussi plaisir c'est de savoir que
justement le héros malheureux de l'an
passé robin leach a décidé de revenir il
y avait vraiment deux écoles chez nous
ceux qui disaient mais a vu ce qui lui
est arrivé l'année dernière il ne
reviendra jamais et d'autres contraire
qu'ils disaient avec ce mot qui est très
à la mode de résidence il va pas rester
à terre il va revenir tout de suite un
peu comme quand on tombe on dit qu'il
faut immédiatement remonté sur le vélo
parce qu'autrement ou à cheval autrement
voilà il ya une appréhension qui est in
est il faut la vaincre tout de suite
donc il sera là il sait très bien et on
sait qu'on aura aussi face à lui
notamment le colombien gagnent bernal
vainqueur de paris-nice en 2019
le dernier qui est gagné paris nice
avant de remporter dans la foulée le
tour de france du côté des français
libres à qui on a les équipes mais on
n'a pas encore les coureurs on sait par
exemple que david goût du sera là il en
fait un objectif il ya trois ou quatre
étapes qui sont faites pour des
grimpeurs puncheurs de son acabit il ya
une arrivée au col de turini le samedi
mais pas simplement on sait que la
dernière étape tout peut jouer le col
d'eze a été revisitée il ya un kilomètre
de route qui n'a jamais été emprunté qui
est très très raide il ya une étape dans
l'ardèche le jeudi avec trois mille
trois cent cinquante mètres de dénivelé
trois cols et cetera
puis un chrono aussi avec un final en
bosses à montluçon donc tout est
possible
paris c'est vraiment un révélateur des
qualités du moment mais aussi bien
évidemment juste avant le printemps au
mois de mars à paris nice on pense
toujours au mois de juillet ça
représente quoi pour un coureur
finalement le paris nice c'est le début
de la saison ça permet d'y croire si je
reprends les exemples de bradley wiggins
ou deguerin thomass qui n'ont gagné
paris nice avant de remporter le tour de
france quand on réussit à vaincre tous
les pièges d'une semaine sur paris nice
parce qu'en fait c'est comme une sorte
de petit tour de france il ya huit
étapes où on peut tout perdre et trois
quatre étapes pour officier de gagner et
c'est vraiment ça c'est quand on sait
notamment depuis 2010 maintenant que
nous sommes chaque année dans les
yvelines pour pour le grand départ que
tout peut se passer dès la première
étape on a vu des coups de bordure les
premiers jours je me souviens de cette
arrivée extraordinaire à bois d'arcy ou
arnaud démare avait battu au sprint juin
philippe puis finissent à deux c'était
vraiment incroyable donc on a retrouvé
ça on a des étapes qui sont très
appréciés dans les yvelines et qui font
des scores d'audience absolument
remarquable et donc il ya le vent
ensuite le lendemain lundi 2 mardi
encore puis un chrono certains vont
tenter de gagner les seconds décisives
et l'autre de ne pas les perdre décisif
pour l'arrivée finale et puis il ya donc
notamment dans l'ardèche et puis le
week-end final dans l'arrière pays
niçois de quoi contenter les meilleurs
grimpeurs du peloton donc ceux qui sont
aptes à gagner paris nice mais aussi
pourquoi pas à gagner derrière le tour
de france vous l'avez souligné la météo
aura son importance 1 chaque année il
soit il fait chaud soit il pleut 1 dans
les yvelines oui là dessus c'est c'est
vraiment ce qui se passe dans les
yvelines et sur paris nice on ne sait
jamais à quoi s'attendre on peut avoir
une semaine rayonnante il peut faire
très froid il peut y avoir du vent il
peut y avoir de la neige ce qu'on a déjà
connu je me souviens il ya déjà quelques
années puisque c'était avant même que je
sois directeur du tour j'étais directeur
adjoint auprès de jean-marie leblanc en
2005 et il a fallu qu'on change deux
arrivées d'étapes et trouve un départ à
cause de l'année je suis ruby jours donc
tout est possible effectivement on est
bien incapable aujourd'hui de dire quel
sera le temps la deuxième semaine de
mars mais ça fait aussi partie des des
charmes et de la légende de paris-nice
et ses coureurs dans la neige au
contraire ces coureurs qui vont dans la
bien nommée course au soleil voilà qui
va fêter sa 80ème édition il est
toujours un moment un moment fort mais
un moment qu'on espère tous de
renaissance aussi bien au delà du sport
cycliste rendez vous le 6 mars prochain
pour la première étape depuis les
yvelines départ depuis mantes la ville
c'est la fin cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]